good morning to everybody uh
I hope everybody had a real Pleasant
summer
humid hot crummy weather but other than
that uh I hope you got some rest and
time away from all this
um one word and by the way I've had some
comments about this bottle I sometimes
have here I'm not trying to sell Hood
milk but it's it's always empty full of
water and so it's my way of keeping
hydrated throughout the the day and I
have to refill it two or three times so
I encourage people here to bring you
know fluids in here and and whether it
be a cup of coffee or or water or tea
exactly I need something like that
yeah what do you have in that flask
okay
uh we've had those in the past not on
this committee had a little bit more
than H2O in in the flask
um so I I'd like to just before we get
into uh our discussion today on 354 and
and and on top of that uh School
building Aid it's a huge topic which we
have before us here and it's critical
it's it's a costly program but it's also
I feel that fourth leg of instruction
and learning if we need to have schools
which house the facilities necessary for
the chemistry labs and for the classroom
space for the conference rooms for
special education on and on it goes and
and keep them current
but I'd like to do just before we get
going on this for the committee here
um to explain some of the things which
have gone on in the last couple days in
this week and previous weeks so that you
can be up to Snuff and I can get a
little feedback from you one of the
things I did do on uh let's see this is
what Thursday was uh uh when on Tuesday
night there was a meeting over at
Concord High School dealing with the
ed306 rules
and I had an opportunity attend that
particular hearing they've been uh these
rule revision which we've talked about
which is really very critical and
important to uh the minimum standards
for public school approval
um have these hearings been occurring
throughout the state and if school
districts request them this is what
meeting was requested by the
superintendent Merrimack and Concord and
it was attended fairly well I thought
there must been about 50 60 people there
uh the issue though uh we if Fred
bramonte who is the previous a previous
chair of the school board for our state
um State Board of Education I mean uh
was there and presented
uh following that there was there's some
questions and some issues which were
brought forward
and I indicated to him we are concerned
that there's portions there which may be
contrary to current statute but also are
eliminating some of the key elements
within subject areas and curriculum
would he please be open to meeting with
the legislative oversight committee or
the education committee he said he would
very much like to do that and so what
I'd like to do with the members are here
is try to find out you know I this I
think we need to do write off in October
sometime
and so are there any dates within
October which would be good for us to
try to get together have Fred in here
and walk through the what the he's you
know have him you know present to us and
then for us to have some open uh q a
with him
and which he's very much open to doing
so
looking at these little things right
here
at the week of the ninth okay let me let
me get in here first okay I gotta
remember my code here to get in this
damn thing
okay
okay looking at October folks
where are these that are open for you
I'll just jot down some of them and I
know that like on October
there's we we have a
I think a subcommittee on 437 on that
date and there's also a CTE advisory
Council
and approximately the same time in the
morning so I that doesn't the
afternoon's available uh what else do we
have not available okay so two is if
you've got you've got
well is that the teacher short of some
of that one too I don't have it my
calendar here well you just scheduled
yesterday okay I I gotta get that in
there okay
um
the week of uh the 16th is really kind
of loaded for myself
uh
I have
um
18 19 20 a lot going on with the
university system New Hampshire as a
trustee so that's not good but I'm
pretty much open in October how about
the weed of the night sometime yeah
the week of the night what do we have
for open on the on the week of the ninth
it'd be good if we could do it later
okay now
that's totally open for me
you're gone on the 13th but the 12th's
good
good so um let me call Fred up and I'll
say we we can meet with him on the 12th
um and then I'll get back by way of
texting or emailing you letting you know
if whether it's the morning or the
afternoon
um what what Fred might be able to do
I'm going to open it up to the
legislative oversight committee and the
and the education committee
do you want to invite sent that down
well Ruth is on the oversight oh maybe
I'm going to let Ruth decide whether she
wants to invite in the with the full
Senate education people
um Ruth by the way was there on Tuesday
night she had leave early to get back up
the highway uh but she said I'd like to
hear more about this so I'm sure they'll
be there too
so the 12th
okay
all right um
is there anything else that we have to
go over there's been a lot going on
we've had the teacher shortage going
meeting going on we've had the
disillusionment uh group for the charter
schools we've had the EFA oversight
committee meeting we've had yesterday
the commission for civics education over
at Granite State
there's a lot going on a lot of issues
are are percolating and
um
it all comes down to Dollars and cents
and
so I'd like to get right now if we if
there's not any other issues on it and
looking at 354 and explain what we'd
like to do today at 11 o'clock we do
have a zoom coming in with a Joel from
the education Commission in the states
dealing with school building Aid
so I'd like to take a break
shortly at right right around 10 30 or
so thereabouts for a short time for the
technology people here to come in and
set it all up and where we can stand and
wander a little bit and then sitting
down three hours in the morning is not
the best thing we healthy thing we
should all be doing
so in the morning what I like to start
out right now is you do have a copy of
the uh some myths I wrote these aren't
official minutes the subcommittees we
usually don't have them but I wrote down
some thoughts immediately following what
we did in June 12 2003 23.
and
um there's on on that page
the following handoffs attached for
provided committee members we we had a
copy of 354.
the list of issues needing resolution
and there is like a through I and
probably a lot more issues were brought
up
welcome Jen how is Alaska
was it really
what time do you get home last night
midnight yeah that that
yeah the red eye is hard to take out of
there
um
well welcome back and we'll we'll keep
you awake
um the list of issues needing resolution
a through I there are not all of them
but is there a way to fund smart
projects alongside or separate from
larger projects I'm this is looking at
school building as a total not just the
chart or the charter school issue how do
Charters fit into the process building
support for emergency projects we have
emergency projects to come up throughout
this state and there could be a charter
or could be a rigor school with arsenic
in the water or a roof that's leaking
where's the funding come up for that
those are emergency situations I'm sure
Amy has some ideas in that do security
and severe safety issues need special
prioritization what is the process for
previously listed applications of set
applications are denied so do they flow
over to the next year do they go to the
top of the Heap
do those projects go to the top of the
list in future considerations should the
state share of Grant Awards be offset by
by sale of facility property equipment
Etc from older facility you know or does
that go back to the district and
um G uh identify funding methods that
ensure long-term sustainability and
identify sources such funds that's a big
one
eight should a flat funding per pupil
Grant system be considered strengths and
weaknesses of that we did have a
proposal as recall before division two
last year that was put forth by
representative hole of having a flat
funding scenario
that's something that I'm sure it's not
going away it's it's coming back at us
the Senate's already putting forward
legislation in that regard
um
how do the following criteria conditions
possibly impact flat funding community
property values family income projected
grade levels and proposed facility
geographic location Democrat
demographics Etc it all goes on should
80 percent of the state Grant be
provided immediately or in consideration
of a lesser percentage divide over the
length of the bond
those were some of the issues which were
brought up in conjunction with Where We
Are
um I have taken the time to do some
exploring and working with some
spreadsheets here which I'm going to
pass out in a little bit here that came
from the ideas came from ECS and some of
the other states which we have out there
and also based upon what we had
presented at division two last year
but the first thing I'd like to do is
talk a little bit about hb354 and the
purpose of that was to provide funding
for Charter Public Schools
I'd like to try to identify clearly some
of those issues which would impact the
funding of the these schools at a 30
percent level
um so I want to open it up right now to
a discussion here as to you know why we
should do this or why we shouldn't do
this or the weaknesses where the
strengths what needs to be resolved
through legislation
any thoughts on it right now
are we all coming in pretty cold in this
topic well I
I think that when we had the initial
discussions on 354 we found that there
were inconsistencies in the statutes
related to whether
funding should be available to school
funding School building Aid funding
should be a
available to Charter Schools so I think
that um you know that's the point that
we start from really on this and
I my consideration is that their Public
Schools so I think that I would side
with the statute that says they are
eligible
and I think that's the direction we
should take
yes
Rick in your uh discussions with the
desolution of
a charter school
was there conversation about the
allocation of the assets
before the assets go from that charter
school we and when we were here to talk
about the dissolution of a charter
school yeah
we it was an organizational meeting
and Senator Lang is now the chair of
that committee we did not get into that
discussion uh it is
on the list of things to do because that
would be one of the concerns that I'd
have I mean even if we did provide
funding for them as a where where do the
assets lie because you've got uh you've
got an independent
um non-profit basically running the
school
and particularly I think if if the
if the school is from the school
district
I mean we have a there was an article in
the paper yesterday
regarding uh the lakes in The Lakes area
where you had the school building that
was going to be going to the Charter
School
and the question that I was having as
you begin to retrofit the building
there's a cost for that I'm assuming
there's a certain amount of startup
costs that the charter school does
receive for the federal government from
the state and so just what happens this
is just a question what do we do with
those assets if in fact there is a
dissolution of the of that particular
Charter School
and if they're going to be looking at
that yeah if I could
um I think there was General agreement
that there needed to be some structure
laid out for dissolution plans they're
pretty much boilerplate
it seems now uh in the uh Charter School
application which is a requirement
um but uh for instance I think with the
charter school you're thinking of
um uh when they submitted their
application and were approved they did
not have a building
now they have a building so
um you know I would agree that uh the
dissolution plan should be Revisited in
those types of circumstances because
it's changed completely at this point
there there's a purchase of sale
agreement and so forth that outlines
some things but I think we need to go
back to the uh application and revise
the dissolution plan in those
circumstances and I I think doe
indicated that
um there were they had looked briefly in
other states don't seem to have too much
in that regard in terms of dissolution
plans either so um but they are
in full agreement that the committee
should head in that direction so so if I
may follow up with one so Glenn are you
saying that um
the doe right now is beginning to look
because we have what
how many we have four or five that have
their own building seven I think we have
seven in this packet here you're going
to see that I handed out there there is
a communication which we got from doe
regarding that
um and it's it's
oh let me get that see if that memo is
in here
yes it is
um it's from town Bayer is it b-a-y-e-r
Amy Amy why don't you we're going to be
talking doe and you have that computer
on your lap there why don't you just
come on up and sit right at one of these
mics at the table up here because if
there's others who want to testify
they're gonna have to replace Amy Amy
watch this come up and just be you know
we've done this many times when we are
asking the technical support from doe
just to participate with us
that way you can
yeah
but the the communication that you see
it's this sheet right in this pack of
material
when I I did communicate with them
and this is from
um
um tal and and Caitlin Davis
says there's 21 schools that lease
there are 11 schools that own
and three schools have not opened yet
but will likely lease
that's there there are a few of the
three I think there's two that are are
now
open I think I think they're opening the
next door next fall down the road and
then the other one is not that sounds
correct there were two that opened this
this current year yep
and and so if if you look at the cheat
just below that sheet that I I'm
referencing right now you can see the
names of the schools and the population
within those schools over the uh
remember when we're looking at a charter
school we're not looking at admr we're
looking at ADM a
because when we when you do uh your
school building Aid Amy you look at the
average of the last five years of admr
um that's correct but it wouldn't apply
here anyway because Charters that's to
calculate the building Aid rate where
charter schools are just a flat 30 so we
don't actually apply the calculation at
all yeah and so but if we were use a
student
population number in there for the grant
the comstab was 30 whatever percentage
we do
then they it would be you have to be an
adma rather than the admr because they
don't have res because they have them
from different residents districts but
they do have attendance correctly just
keep in mind that um if you were I guess
what you're saying is if you were to put
them in the building Aid calculation we
could use adma instead of admr but the
other factor in there is median family
income so we'd also have to solve that
problem the building Aid rate is a
function of those two things medium
family income and uh equalized valuation
for people right yes yeah that that
impacts the 30 to 60 percent I I get
that but if we had a flat rate of 30
percent
irregardless of ADM correct or
regardless of medium family income or
the other just it's flat 30 flat Thirty
and if we had the population would be an
average or would it be of the previous
year
it's um a little more complicated
of course
um it actually isn't really that
complicated it's a ranking so it's a
ranking where you fall within the state
that's why the building Aid rates don't
change very much even if median family
income changes or equalized valuation
per pupil because it's where you rank
within the state
um
explain that a little bit more so the
building Aid calculation is essentially
the median family income you rank all
the municipalities then you find the
equalized valuation per pupil using admr
and you rank those and the average of
those rankings you enter a table so that
like let's say if you were number one in
the median family income and you were
number 20 in equalized valuation per
pupil that's where your rank is you
would average those I should have picked
better numbers but the average of 21
which is ten and a half you take that
number 10 and a half and you'd enter the
table to see what building Aid rate you
fall into there's bracketed uh rates for
what they call the building Aid Factor
okay I understand that I thought you're
talking about the ranking of the
applications oh no no the rate the rank
from The Medium family income and
ranking of equalizer
so
um
they answer the question I believe
there's seven is that correct seven
owned uh it sounds right but I'm not
sure I don't
yeah well according to this memo right
here
it's about that
so
so the disillusionment and the there
there's a lot of issues
um do you give building Aid to a charter
would you give building a to a charter
school if the building they're in didn't
meet
Life Safety fire safety codes and
no
um not only um to Charter Schools
um would not receive building a they
also wouldn't be occupying that for
um student occupancy so it's not really
a question about building Aid it's that
they're a public school and have to meet
all the same regulations same similar
with private schools private schools
have certain safety regulations that
they're required to meet to public
schools have more more requirements but
they wouldn't be operating a facility if
they did not meet their life and health
and safety requirements okay
so what I'd like to do is just take a
second and explain this pack the
materials I just gave you
so that
um
this is
11 are you still looking at that so
one two three four five six seven eight
well ten right owned one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
yeah see that's that's probably on
purpose because they don't they don't
have it's virtual so they don't have a
building for students
yep
okay uh that the second sheet are going
underneath this one identifies
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten charters
and it lists their adma
for since 2018 through 2022 I I went
back five years simply because we go
back five years for the other side as an
average but uh and but was it that's
admr this is ADM a
um
the the highlighted in in black is the
average
um
of the five years
the the lighter color below whereas um
for example like the academy for science
design which has 528 kids in it the
average is 526 if we use the average of
five years the average for three years
would be 529 and if you use the most
recent year which would 2020 would be
528.
um so that's what the lighter color is
the lighter color is the average of
three years
some of them don't have for example if
you come down to
Gathering Waters uh Charter School
it's I got an adma for the one year 2022
so that if we used a one year that would
be sliding over there and that's what
we'd use
but this lists what their populations
are
some of those are pretty good sized
schools with over 500 kids in them
so the number of kids
that
are in The Five-Year average for own
Charter Schools is 1 409 kids and for
the three years is one thousand four
hundred forty six it's very very close
very close
so and then if you were to add in the
the one that has just the one year it'd
be a little higher
I don't know I didn't see anything for
Benjamin Franklin or Heartwood public
pardon me
they just opened they just opened
so obviously this is a growing list of
schools
and Facilities
Amy when when we have these new schools
coming in what's the process that the
doe does to recognize someone the State
Board approves
do they ask about the facility itself
unfortunately I don't know um towel
would take them through the um the
school board approval for Charter
procedure for the facility approval
which is separate because that happens
after you can't get a facility unless
you know your Charter is going to be
approved by the state board so after
um they have a charter that's approved
by the state board they if they want a
facility that's approved then they go
through our facility approval process
which is making sure that they have a
emergency operation plan on file that
they have their certificate of occupancy
and they have a approval by the town
they don't have asbestos in their
building they're testing their water
drinking water for lead and things like
that
[Applause]
um representative black can I um is this
the table that you were going over
I I hadn't started yet I was gonna I was
gonna
this is just an example has some just
some numbers in there which you know are
not solid but it's it's a concept which
we're going to have something very
similar coming at us only not using any
square footage called based upon
population from the Senate
so a lot of issues let me explain what
we got here in front of you in this
thing so we can go through it this is
the sheet that looks like this
and this is in regard to both Charters
and public schools
I went through and looked at other
states and I kind of latched on to the
state of Tennessee and several others
which have a formula
which is sustainable and predictable one
of the issues which we have with school
building Aid right now is that you saw
the list we had come to Amy when there
were 17 applications in last go around
how many did you approve three or two
have been approved and we're waiting for
the next waiting here next for our other
funding so all these school districts
in order to get that application in here
they've had to put forth a lot of
dollars with Architects with Engineers
trying to get this application in so it
can be looked at as Amy's Amy does
they have to put forward 70 80 000
easily
and they're saying we didn't get an
award
but we had to put forth all this money
and yet
by the time we get an application
approved which might be 10 years from
now
that may have be done again
so they're saying and the people in the
communities are saying that's an expense
that is uh difficult to you know get
approved through the voters to go to
that site plan site design and all that
which is done through Architects and
engineers
so what
what the idea I think that J.R Hull is
trying to present and that was
um one which it was very quick Amendment
and there was a lot of holes in it and
we couldn't go with it but he was trying
to come up can we do something that's
more predictable
so a school district knows that they're
going to have X number of dollars
available
and they can plan for that 10 15 years
down the road
and that is a type of an uh uh formula
that
I'm trying to do something right here
with I'm not necessarily sold on it I'm
just presenting it to us for discussion
purposes only
so the formula has in the spreadsheet
these columns a b c d e f g h in in the
bottom
um
if you look at formula going across and
we have extras of these of people out
here want to
have a copy and follow along with us
okay
yeah and there's a few more right here
as well
um Glenn if you need more of them
thank you
okay everybody I think it probably has a
copy right now
um so looking at the First Column a
that's just your District identification
number
column B is you're going across the
spreadsheet identifies the community or
the school district this is exactly what
we have in current law the the districts
right there
the next column across is your admr for
that school district and it's an average
of the five years prior to this
so that would give you a pretty accurate
understanding of what your residence
student population is like
correct me if I'm wrong on that Amy
you're doing good okay so far okay so
far okay then then in this particular
yes
that that's a diff that's referencing
Charters okay okay so this is right now
we're jumping to a formula which would
be for the rigor right here if it was
the charter as you even looked in the
The Proposal was put forth by represent
a whole there was another line and
that's in back in the back of this
handout which you got
this amendment was
yeah it's Amendment uh to hb2
it's it's it's it's it's there and you
notice that
he has on line 14 through line 16 the
admr for the school districts but notice
it's adma and line 20 and through 22.
for the charters
so
it's like apples and oranges
so you would well he had it that you
would get 30 of your ADM
a
in in the bill
that for his flat model
so there's a couple of variables the
three three that that's that is that's a
variable it's it's different than than
it would be for districts that's what
I'm trying to go through right now
um see if as you're going across the
spreadsheet D what I did is I looked at
what they had years ago down in
Tennessee not years ago about five six
years ago cost of construction
and the cost of construction
was based upon square footage per pupil
now I've used just for ease of doing
this I took an average because the cost
if you took square footage per pupil for
an elementary school a middle school and
the high school they're different
and some of the differences that they
have in law
that was in that report that I looked at
was that the elementary
per pupil square footage was used back
then was 105 square feet
for the middle school was 110 for a high
school was 130.
I went through and calculated the
percentage of kids in the state which
are in high schools 9 through 12.
it's about 32 33 percent of our student
population
and K through 8 is the other
and so taking the average of these
numbers I came up and used to figure 114
square feet it could be changed any
figure you want to use you can use
but that suggests to get this concept
across so that square footage was
multiplied
at 114 square foot per pupil
and at 153 dollars per square foot
the cost in Allenstown for example for
the costler project would be 9.5 million
dollars
but there's other costs
which are part of this other than just
the building a building
um with with a contractor and the other
costs include
costs for equipment which is put inside
the building so an additional 10 percent
was put on there it's on the front seat
architect fees seven percent
and there's a 20-year debt retirement at
six percent
so it takes care of the debt so it's a
total of 123 percent
uh is a hundred percent for the cost
that we have there in the column
um
the let's see well the one that says 9.5
that column multiply that by 123
percent
the cost of that building would now be
11.7 million dollars
it's a district which gets 60 percent
based upon their rate of medium family
income and equalize valuation per pupil
sixty percent of for the state multiply
times that 11.7 million would come out
to seven million dollars
spread over a period a life cycle of 40
years
the amount that they would receive
annually would be a hundred and seventy
six thousand forty nine dollars 81 cents
annually that would go to the district
the concept we're looking at this money
would not go to the district it would
stay in a building fund controlled by
the state treasurer
and the interest would go back into the
pot that this money is constantly
gaining
the
the purpose of this whole money is for
renovation and construction I'm not
changing the rationale or that we use
currently for building Aid and to access
this money it's there for the towns but
they still have to complete their
application that with meeting the
criteria and the standards and that
would go through doe and doe would then
authorize the use that money from that
fund that's theirs over a period of time
um that's the basic concept behind this
if you look at the bottom line on this
type thing on the fourth page the cost
of this for the state would be 38
million dollars annually
we also have a debt or a tail which
we're paying off and saying it's roughly
25 million dollars 24 million dollars
somewhere around that neighborhood
adding that on top of appropriating 50
million dollars isn't going to do it
we'd have to appropriate somewhere
closer to 60 something or 75 million
dollars to get this thing going
and there may be some money left over in
the pot I know I'm going through a lot a
lot here but the money that could that
like the interest money gain could be
used for emergency projects
uh projects which need immediate
attention that the state recognizes need
to be done this is a concept which is
very similar to what Senator Lang is
bringing forward on I don't think he's
using the square footage and all that
this this formula right here would if
it's done properly would even break it
down for square footage by the number of
kids that are middle Elementary and high
school within each district
yeah Cassandra
yeah
guys that's if you find it all those
projects yes annually
and of course it would change over the
years based on population shifts and the
averages there but this is what you
would get for example let's look at
Berlin
right where it's 60 you're 60 yeah
um
uh went across here so you would be seen
each year 349
113.26 right and the town would have to
come up with 10 million so I'm just
looking at the two and you have to come
up with either State share for your
project is about 13 right no your
project would total cost additional cost
would be
94 million dollars no that's Bedford
just look down one oh okay excuse me 23
23 yes yes and I was on the wrong line
and the state would be about 13. that's
right so the city would have to come up
with about 10. I mean just to round
things off
so that total at the last on the last
page of 38 million is to is that annual
allocation that every single School
District potentially would get yes okay
yeah got it thanks on this for me now if
you were to change it for example over a
30-year life expect cycle
you jump it by another 10 million
dollars it'd be 48 million dollars
that would be the mathematics involved
but we try there's a lot of anything to
change in this is going to right it's
going to have a ripple effect across a
spreadsheet this is a the concept that
was brought up at division two yeah but
it wasn't as thorough as this or brought
in some of those conditions are criteria
so it's something that the legislature
is probably going to be faced with
having to make a decision how are we
going to do this so so this this concept
is basically creating a bank account
for each School District
Reserve funding right and and and the
state basically reserves that money
until the school district says we want
to build a project
yeah and you could have some small
districts saying after two years well I
want to do this I want to do this
maintenance maintenance is not the same
part of this right here that's important
so that's important there has to be a on
this concept there has to be some kind
of a Clearinghouse an approval process
so you still want to be building
according to the standards that we
expect for a Schoolhouse to be
just a question so the assumption is so
I get this right the assumption is that
over this course of these x amount of
years 20 years 30 years 40 years every
school district in the state will need
to build something
even though if they don't know that the
Assumption the way that's written
here you have the life of a building is
unless everything is wrong I just think
that's that's what tuition on the same
page that's the concept okay the other
issue is does this money go into a
reserve account within the school
district or is it held outside
and all that invested so then from that
you get interest
and you could you build with that bigger
pot and that would pay off some of our
debt faster
for the state
um it also with any other of that
Surplus interest and there would be with
that amount of money accruing that would
give that option for emergency
applications so uh under this plan
could one school district
borrow money from another school
district I'm serious I mean if if if one
had we don't have any building plans for
the next five or six years and we've got
this pot of money here so sure we'll
loan it to you assuming that when we get
ready to do some billing we might be
able to borrow it back from you I mean
it's just a question whether or not
that's part of this plan or is it just
singly singularly
identified per School District in a big
account because I think the float you're
talking about
of 38 million dollars or whatever it is
is a lot more than 13. so I think so
that was just it's and I'm not raising
this to be funny but I'm just because I
know somebody's going to think about
that oh yeah sure it's like going down
the black hole here but I I I think that
that it would have to be for that school
district
and before the school district's gonna
be able to access their pot of money
they're going to have to demonstrate to
the doe that it's paralleling the
standards and criteria that we expect a
Schoolhouse look like and they see that
it's not just maintenance or custodial
type work it is truly renovation and
that those start standards we have
currently in place yeah I would assume
that it is just per School District
because yes so Robin Peter to pay Paul
yeah
I I think the question also would play
into is that money kept in the state
account yes or in a local account if
it's a local account you know oh no who
knows no I I if this if you go into this
kind of thing it's got to be held in the
state yeah absolutely definitely
Amy what are your thoughts on this I
know you've had this this this whole
thing presented we went through it last
year
the concept
so I would just keep in mind
um that this process would be excellent
in 40 years because a school will have
banked enough money
um
to potentially have a construction
project but for example in Berlin that
example
that 13.9 million dollars that you
pointed out just keep in mind that
that's not going to be available for 40
years the the account is going to get
349 000 for 40 years so that means
for a for a real construction project
349 thousand dollars is not going to do
anything for Community
um
the actual construction costs for a
total project run about 500 to 600 per
square foot
um I realize there's a there's a 23
addition here uh in the calculation but
so
for New England for our projects
um across the country they are not at a
hundred and fourteen dollars per square
foot so like I realized this is a table
and you can plug in different numbers
and a concept but when you start talking
about a total of 38 million we really
could be talking about a three times
that really could be talking about 120
million or so I I get that yeah I
understand I just want to make sure
other people understood because there
was a question about the 13 million like
running this process
parallel to a process
um to assist schools that haven't
already been built you know their
buildings are already 70 80 years old so
it just for me it makes me nervous
because it feels like a little bit of a
delay for 40 years before you get
something actually up and running but
running it in parallel I mean the
concept ultimately is great had we
thought about it 40 years ago so why not
why not start now I'm not saying that
that that's why not start now that's
great just I'm thinking it probably
needs to run along a parallel program to
fund schools now yeah that was the
criticism
the transition period of getting to
where you want this thing functioning
it's going to take a lot of time and
there's issues out there we know that
that need attention but we're not
addressing them either now under our
situation right three possible projects
out of 17
uh and and
I've talked to several superintendents
their their biggest concern is
predictability how can I and
sustainability
how can I predict
I can do this building here this year
and and that helps the voters understand
that too so under our present situation
it's a crap shoot you should submit your
application you may or may not get it
so and then the only other thing I'd say
is it probably should be some kind of
price index each year because you know
if you delay a project one year you're
probably already going to lose 349 000
you know on these you know our projects
are coming just for like scale you know
we're talking about uh 20 million dollar
project is a is a cheap project these
days for a small you know we're talking
about 20 30 40 90 we're main you know
because that's a good comparison Maine
Massachusetts isn't always the best
comparison but Maine is already building
um schools over 100 million dollars and
so just like scale wise obviously it
depends on the type of school
um and the number of students there but
we're still talking about large projects
so just keeping in mind that scale
that's all I would say and that scale is
important you know I I built School up
in Alaska was at that time 96 million
dollars it's a high school
we had oil money to do it but
it's uh over nine dollars a barrel today
um it's so we have buildings like that
in this state too that are potential for
that that would wipe out what we're
doing in our present formula we would
never be able to accomplish that with 80
up front
so so we have a quandary here as far how
we're going to handle this so Amy um as
you look at your
your spreadsheet or whatever your uh
your Ouija board you use to look at this
stuff how is there a differentiation
between new construction
vis-a-vis that of renovation
is there is there a differentiation
between priority as far as a new
building vis-a-vis a retrofitting an
older building no there wouldn't be a
priority and I'd say more our
communities are
cost wise it used
that you see easy cheaper to do
renovation but that's not always the
case the costs are really relatively
similar and so there's a big push to
focus more on renovation not from the
department but just
um globally or Community wise it can be
more sustainable schools are used to
having that building in their community
and they're attached to it and it
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
saving money or not for renovation
versus you know
yes
just a quick question what do you
consider the life cycle of a building
yeah 40 years is good I mean in 40 years
is uh 40 years is what the data shows to
say that
um after 40 years you're looking at some
uh significant deterioration of a
building of a school building
specifically
of that type of building
so I I think the concept is good because
I I think if you look at big picture
it's like
okay New Hampshire needs to invest in
its school buildings
I mean I have a school 98 years old the
other one 51 years old
and with the biomass going down the
tubes
um will never come up with 10 million
dollars you know raised locally
but if there was
some plan that we knew down the road I
think 40 years is a long time because
then you got to start almost all over
again don't you
if that time were a little bit shortened
and I'm watching Littleton that's gone
through that situ you know this process
for years yes and Colebrook going
through it
who knows maybe years you know
who who knows right
um but I like the idea
of the investment in our buildings for
our kids
because like I say they vary all over
the state and I really wanted to get a
survey out find out how many schools
actually had that double vestibule
entrance for school safety
because I know ours do not because we
never could generate the local funds
you know to be able to do that on a 98
year old building but I know there are a
lot of other small towns that have
particularly older buildings and they're
The Hub of those communities but I do
like that concept of looking
at that big picture
so that there's hope for every District
that's what I hear from a lot of
superintendents they they're looking for
predictability
experience can I go back to a comment
you made
um Rick's chives predicating the the
numbers on the 114 square foot right
that's all right and you you said the
average cost in Hampshire is five to six
hundred
uh correct for the total project cost so
that would I think in the table it's
114. uh 153 and then there's a 23 bump
so 180 dollars a square foot let's run
this table it's yours basically you're
talking three times that
um approximately yeah in Baltimore okay
so these numbers would be three times
that
okay thank you
um also the square footage um is 114 on
the table and our state average that
that schools cannot meet in design is
approximately 140 square feet we're
really closer to 180. it does depend
Elementary Middle High but that 140 we
have not seen a school be able to meet
that with the special education
um spaces that are needed and
um and keeping class sizes down to
closer to 20 than 25. I'm not sure about
Tennessee but uh in New Hampshire the 20
is
um where people you know the schools are
kind of floating yeah it's amazing so
you're saying 140 would be the minimum
minimum or 180.
um minimum would be 140 140 square feet
but then I made in that threshold
um it varies I'm trying to think of the
numbers that's got categories of you
know the the smaller your school is
population wise the more square foot per
pupil you need because you still need a
cafeteria space you still need a gym
space right
um but I would say the average is
between if you wanted to use an average
150 to 1
70 or 80. the range though is probably
140 to 200 like if you wanted to think
like wow 120 square feet per pupil
that's a tight spool
um and they've got their spaces like
probably really maximized and then 200
square feet per pupil is
um is closer to probably that school has
a lot of special education or special
services in there in in their school
districts okay thank you thank you
so one of the questions I'd have too um
first
I I wonder if this is kind of a
multi-prong approach would be better
because I think of the schools that are
in line for building ad but they're
number four five on the list and they
come away with with nothing where as in
under this program at least they'd have
something in the bank but we can't do
you know we can't fund both things at
the same time with this the pot of money
that we have but I wonder if we could
tweak it enough that you could still
move on everybody could still move on
rather than depending on one for source
of funding and that's that very short
list every year
okay now the question I would have how
do you deal with the projection of
student population
when you begin to look at either
renovating a building or building a new
building
how do you know what the student
population is going to be in 10 years
for example
yeah that's a very very good question in
order to apply for building Aid you have
to submit some statistical analysis of
your projected population on those
projections in a lot of schools are
going down
um so we use the Cur whatever their
current enrollment is for sizing the
school
it is a little risky because there are
some
enrollment if you are not talking about
alternative types of Education
enrollment could look like does come in
waves so there could be an uptick I know
that's not a popular statement
um but um that is what like a lot of the
enrollment
experts say but then you have to compare
that with alternative types of Education
impacting public schools and and it's
really difficult to to project
um so we don't see many designs we see
schools proposing for some increase in
population depending on the school
district but the state doesn't pay for
that portion of that increase we cap it
at their existing enrollment numbers if
they're declining
okay now what we also
have to always consider is we have a
debt we're paying off
uh on top of for example just going the
flow there and let's say we had
something where was 38 million dollars
which we obligate this year or whatever
year it might be
in looking at the chart right here
we handed out the last one the tail and
the debt for FY 2425
the total obligations
are close to 50 million bucks
so we appropriate 50 million dollars
supposedly each year so that leaves 50
million dollars left but that drops off
very quickly here so if I go down let's
say to
fy2829 the debt is
27 million dollars total so it's in the
present formula it's going to give us
more money for school construction and
renovation
but it's still not going to catch up
with the needs which we have
uh with a formula like this if the money
were invested
and if you put 38 or 50 million dollars
in the pot or 60 million you'd have to
put 38 million plus the debt for let's
say
another 50 million on top of that
to pay off the debt if you're it's it's
it's going to come up more than what we
are presently allocating anyway I think
you shake or bake this it's going to
have to be more money to start out so
you can build up that state pot and the
interest will then help accrue and take
care of some of those immediate issues
in that transition process
I don't have the figures in that because
I haven't done that calculation as far
as what the interest would garnish
against us
can yes um could I just put a reminder
out there to because I feel like this
gets lost sometimes that 50 million
dollar cap was put in place in 2013.
um and I just want people to remember
that in the late 2000s 2009 maybe even
2010 the state was spending over 60
maybe even 64 million dollars per year
at that time
um before that cap if you account the
bond in 2010 when that started too so
like just thinking about the amount of
money that we were spending was more
back in 2009 2010 2011 than it is now
it's just something to keep in mind too
I think that the kind of gets lost
because the cap is there in the law but
it was a number that could be
sustainable yeah and then I also want to
point out uh since this is a work
session I did run some numbers
um
um for you all because this this chart
here there's another
potential mesh with what you have here
too and that's that keep in mind that
the state my Bureau has all the all
construction projects prior to the
moratorium were funded through the
Department of Education there was no
ranking list they put an application in
and the state funded that share okay so
again I think it's very important to not
lose sight that that those projects were
funded all of them prior to the
moratorium so this because of that we
have a very robust list of projects all
the way back
um
we have them in paper form back from the
40s and 50s but we have them all in a
database from 1970 and on so if you kind
of wanted to mesh this with a credit of
some schools have already received some
square footage then you could do that
you could do something potentially like
you know if you got
I don't mean to make this too technical
but if you got so much square footage
built last year then that could come off
your credit at a hundred percent right
because it was just built last year and
then you could traction that off 40 40 1
over 40 is two and a half percent so you
could take two and a half percent and
reduce that every year which means that
somebody that took building Aid and
built you could take their square
footage and reduce it by two and a half
percent each year as you go back
something to
kind of shift some of that money to
districts that haven't tapped into
building a for a long time and then
shift less money to those districts that
have received building Aid in the last
40 years and then the last number I
wanted to put out there is that
um just again for scale
um the state
um funded
uh in over a 37-year period that happens
to be from 1973
um to 2009 before the moratorium
um 27 million square feet of Renovations
and additions uh to schools and that
average square footage I can put this
all in numbers and I can confirm my
numbers later but that average square
footage is about 700
000 square feet per year that the
program was operating at that time if
you take that and multiply it by 550 a
square foot and you apply the average
rate of 38 percent you come out to be
154 million dollars of state aid per
year so just giving you that kind of
um
the take home math on that is if you
were to compare today's dollars to what
the program was doing prior to the
moratorium it's approximately in today's
dollars about 154 million if you were to
look at the last
um since 1973 to prior to Marge for you
so some numbers fruits are thought I
don't know if that confuses things it
makes things better or we were funding
all Commerce you put an application in
it was approved
um well that's not no that's not true it
was approved under the regulations the
only projects that were eligible were
approved they still had caps on square
footage they still had caps on the a
dollar amount
um I understand that Amy but if they
they complied with all the standards the
criteria they were approved correct
correct now it's not that way corrects
okay and that is limited right we were
in terms of the rest of states in this
country funding at about the average
level around 20th or 29th somewhere in
that in of the states now we're nowhere
near that we're at Rock Bottom correct
so it has changed and our debt was
significant back then you know it you
know it was 540 plus million dollars
so so we I I what I'm just trying to say
is that I think we have come to the
point where we got to do something here
there's got to be a transition plan
there's got to be some kind of formula
and we've got to help the school
districts uh ah yeah we have buildings
that don't have an Arctic our entry
areas that are secure
we have Littleton grade school which is
two-story building that's just some
trouble we've got Colebrook right now
they can't get the bonding done to do
their school
so
there's got to be some answers to this
and I I think that we can't just keep
tweaking the formula we and I know
there's legislation you you've given me
to try to put forward here regarding the
10-year plan and all that and the
application process
that's good we'll we'll do we'll do that
but uh somehow we've got to really shift
our gears a little bit here and and plan
for
more than just this year
so how to be Forward Thinking uh
we've got to be we gotta do something
that's true now in looking at this
spreadsheet too if you go to the next
sheet Beyond
if you took this formula
and applied it to Charter Schools
there is one sheet that looks sort of
like this in the in the bundle
like this
and if and I I took a three-year average
I should have just taken the last year
of adma uh but a rate you can see what
the state share would be for those
buildings because there are very few of
them there's only like seven or so I
used square footage not a whole lot of
square footage so the annual cost for
the whole state all Charter Schools will
be around 232 thousand dollars
annually
and if you look at the last one of those
I put one in there for a specific School
uh Academy for Science and design they
would receive 85 000 a year out of this
out of this pot if it's funded at 30
percent
using the same type of formula
so the charter schools are not going to
eat a whole lot out of this the biggest
elephant in the room is the school
districts the charter schools are very
insignificant they basically have a
little less than two percent of our
student population
foreign
that's just more informational for you
right there what it would cost so is
this based upon the whole formula yeah
yeah I I when I did the formula because
I couldn't throw at this in because uh
there's no five-year average there's
none of that for the of the resident
they don't have resident they use adma
and so but the formula you can see is
basically is similar
um
and the state shares over 40 years it
was based upon a flat 30 percent for all
charter schools
and it came out to that level
so in the in the grand picture the big
picture of the charter schools have they
become part of this and the funded at
that level is not going to be a
significant amount of money
yes
can I ask why they're put at 30 percent
there's they don't fit in the formula
that's in law right now isn't it
right now okay so it's not now this not
arrived at the same way but that's a
statute correct I don't know how it got
there it's a minimum it's the minimum
yeah I think that's in the law yep
well how would you figure out
medium family equalized property
valuation and all that that'd be a huge
issue with the charter school seeing the
kids come from various districts
or towns
I think that'd be a huge huge
well that's why I asked because it
sounds
amazing
have you had inquiries from Charter
Schools before building a yes I'm sure
that Charter Schools would like to
um you know be able to fill out an
application we've had Charter Schools
fill out an application it's a it's an
easy ad for us I mean like to our to our
list you know it's not like it's
overwhelming we'll get one charter
school probably every once in a while
that would probably put an application
in uh in there in uh it is for
substantial the current laws it's for
substantial renovation and new
construction so it's not a I think
sometimes it's not just charter schools
public school districts too might
misunderstand that what the purpose of
building Aid is and want to do a roof or
you know a window project or things like
that that are not eligible
so
letting you have more information
tonight
when a charter school
when a charter school initiates its
program
and it has a site that it's in
does it get Federal money
for the site development or the Building
Development
Etc how how is that currently worked if
I'm starting a charter school and I
let's say I don't own a building I'm
just I want to lease it but I need to to
retrofit
Etc what's what's the difference there
is a small lease Aid so that was what it
represents on the lease this morning too
weren't you or talk about the lease
program well I can yeah I think it'd be
good then you're hitting our topic we
need to address in terms of the federal
funding that's available
I'm not sure how much of that is
available for
um you know startup with a building I
don't think very much I
um I know that the building that was
purchased by our local charter school
that's going to be starting up they're
talking about I think it's at least
seven or eight hundred thousand dollars
in renovations to get started to open
the door including ADA compliance and
safety compliance with egress and and so
forth and where does that where does
that money get generated from obviously
not from they're talking about having to
raise it okay so uh there well actually
I think yeah okay yeah
um uh probably going to do a mortgage
instruction mortgage
um and then factor into their budget the
that annual cost of
that loan that debt all right it's going
to eat the he's speaking about the one
in OSP yeah I thought they got about 1.1
million started from Federal
right but I don't think that they can
use that for the renovation of the the
building
thank you
Amy I'll double check but I don't think
it's about I I it's broken I think
earlier that we have to have an
understanding of the lease program how
does that work
so the lease aid program so it does fall
under RSA 19815 so it falls under the
building Aid regulations but they're a
separate appropriation so the building
appropriation is to school districts
that own their own building lease eight
is to charter schools that lease
buildings uh and so the Lee said right
now is 30
of the eligible costs in at least 30
each 50 000. you've capped out at fifty
thousand dollars correct um and I I
don't have the numbers in front of me
but I'm gonna ballpark it and say half
the schools receive the full 30 and half
the schools are subject to the cap
um so in this new formula you write like
Academy of Science design getting 85 000
per year that's a really big win for
them because if they were to lease a
building they'd only get 30 percent uh
uh I mean fifty thousand dollars thirty
percent up to fifty thousand dollars so
Academy for Science and design is
definitely one of those that gets capped
significantly by lease aid but um other
school this other charter schools are
being able to pay the Department of
Education through lease aid pays for
that full 30 percent
and it's and it's it's separate than
building AIDS so what we do is we take
the appropriation and appropriate it if
we don't have enough money then we
prorate everybody at the same rate if we
ran out of money we might only end up
paying them 85 percent of what their
award would have been because that's all
the money we have this year we will not
be um doing any
um prorating because we have enough uh
funds to how much do we appropriate a
year for a lease a uh it's changed over
the just like the moratorium lisaid was
also not funded I I believe maybe the
last three years this might be our third
or maybe our fourth year of funding
um
I am again who can't promise these
numbers are accurate but I think the
first year it was like 200 000 or 250
000 for lease Aid and I think we
prorated everybody we cut their payments
by like 60 because we couldn't it wasn't
even near enough so then the next uh
biennium they uh appropriated
um I think a half a million dollars and
then they also increased the cap it went
from thirty thousand dollar cap to a
fifty thousand dollar cap and I think
we've still had to prorate schools
um maybe
90 uh we were able to give them 90 of
their award and then the last two years
we've given about 100 percent
but that's a separate project it's a
separate budget line item correct the
this current biennium it's 850 000 per
year that we have for lease Aid
and I think the requests are somewhere
near six hundred thousand dollars so we
had enough money assist lease program
just for Charter Schools or for
districts as well it's just for Charter
Schools we don't have any school
districts that at least anyway but it is
the the law actually we say it actually
covers Career and Technical Education
Centers too but the law I don't know if
it's in House Bill 2 or somewhere along
the appropriation the appropriation of
that 850 000 says that it's only for
Charter Schools even though lease Aid is
available for Career and Technical
Education Centers as well with that said
I don't know of any career in technical
Education Centers at least so nobody has
any heartburn over that requirement but
um in the law it's specific to Charter
Schools
the appropriation is
a lot to this
we heard the other day in the
dissolution we were trying to figure out
uh there are schools that start out
Leasing but then end up buying and
owning
but when the charter was initially
written there is no no language or you
know
for the possible dissolution of
something eventually they've owned
and so so the dissolution according to
what we heard from Caitlin is basically
a boilerplate of several issues
that
many places are using but there's no
real definition am I correct Glenn and
where I'm going with this I think so
yeah
we didn't have time to look at them
we're going to have more coming to us
because this was just an organizational
meeting
but uh
thank you
charges that granted
I think there's something business side
of him
his own
is that okay
I I couldn't honestly tell you that
there there are some charters in trouble
yeah but uh uh in looking at these
numbers of attendance that we see here
some when we see school has 298 kids
call 300 kids Seacoast
and you look at the science academy uh
they're they're pretty good micro
Society Academy those are are fairly
good-sized schools
and and
the grade levels I don't know what
specifically their grade levels most of
them don't have a high school mostly the
science and design does
so going back then of course we we're
going to take a break here in about
seven minutes here so we accept the zoom
that's what we told the people for the
ECS they're going to come in and talk
more about funding plans and
possibilities for for public school
buildings
um
I guess are there any further questions
on this right now I think we should come
down and say
do we move forward or where are we on
funding of some type for charter schools
are we
are we recognizing that the they do need
some support or we're already doing a
lease program
my first
sorry yeah what was I talking how to
turn
um
I think we need to address the building
aid program first before we expand it
and then once we have a system in place
then it makes sense to include Charter
but we have so many buildings that are
in tough shape
um
that we have to prioritize just when the
applications come in with the monies
that we have now they have to be
prioritized
you should go ahead Glenn um
we have to build pending the routine for
Charter School building I think 354 too
right I need to address that
um this just today in New Hampshire
Business Review an article as Charter
Schools expand in New Hampshire the push
is on to find more space enrollment
numbers policy changes are creating
tensions
um there is
uh a growing number of charter schools
and I think that we have to their Public
Schools we have to support them as well
I think I think
we have to also Define
or the asset who owns yes
because when you're going to be dealing
with public companies going to a private
entity
and unless I'm wrong
a chart a public charter school is run
by a non-profit independent agents
in all the cases today there is the
option for a district
um to do a charter school right
um right
um and and in that instance Glenn
there's no question in my mind where the
facility is and who owns it but when
you've got
the number that we have now they're
growing
that are in fact independent groups
receiving public monies that are now
going to have assets
that that to me the desolution question
the group looking at that I'm assuming
they're going to look to see where do
those assets go what does it mean to
have an asset who owns it
when it's being paid for with public
monies I mean that that is a to me
that's a threshold question
that needs to be answered I think before
we start talking
about
building Aid further building Aid going
in I mean that's it only seems logical
to me to have that understanding first
except because right now Amy I'm I'm
assuming it's it's not clear
who owns the asset
I guess I would just keep in mind the
way this house bill 354 is written
um that they're only getting 1 20th of
the payment like the trying to mimic the
term of the bond right so
so I'm trying to figure out like what
would be the difference between lease
Aid paying every year and building Aid
every year to a charter school it's not
like they're getting the 80 percent up
front like the public district schools
are so to me it's the same risk as
lisaid you know they're the least say
they're receiving and they're paying
their landlord
um we're building Aid they're putting
into an asset
um we would have the ability if they um
dissolved after two years to stop paying
building AIDS so we would recoup 18
years of we would not be paying 18 years
up there
um
their building Aid payment if that makes
sense I feel like that that's the reason
that was in there was to to address
those asset concerns
um stop right there for a second if in
fact we have in law that
let's say Berlin
has taken building a for school building
a
they closed School building Aid a down
five years later
I understand my reading was they got to
pay back
that building Aid they had to improve
building a that is correct is that the
same deal with the charter schools that
is also correct but it's just a matter
of trying to figure out how
a charter school goes under right that
if they go bankrupt how do we actually
get that money back I'm just saying like
with the public school district it might
be easier to do with a charter school
you might be running a little bit more
risk but is it really that much risk
because you just essentially paid them
up a 120th payment every year which is
kind of equivalent to lease Aid you're
paying a a bill every year to somebody
else who owns the asset for me I I don't
um
see with the Rook with the new language
remember this language wasn't here when
the when you first saw the bill but now
that this bill is in here and you're
paying 120th of the building Aid and it
also gets to
um kind of Representative cascadden's
concern like about the amount of dollars
um the amount of dollars that would be
appropriated
um to that Charter School let's say the
charter school ranks higher than the
Public District school and they're
seeking most likely they're seeking a
lot less money than a public school
district because they're in typically
smaller but let's say they're building
Aid they're seeking 1 million in
building Aid We're going to be paying
them
fifty thousand dollars a year
um so
um fifty thousand dollars a year is what
they would be taking whereas a public
District school would be maybe seeking
40 million dollars like they just don't
um I don't see that as being a big
threat to the Billy Aid bucket having
charter schools there just so but again
just process wise I'm I'm not here to
I'm just trying to formulate process
wise it doesn't seem like that would
play a role
yes thank you I I I agree I I wouldn't
like to see
Charter Public Schools that have made
the investment of buying a building be
disqualified because they have put down
Roots you know and if other schools are
getting lease Aid
um I think that's made a step in the
right direction to get a building and I
don't think they should be penalized for
that
one of the things we did have before the
dissolution meeting started I handed Tim
Lang
um the and you can look it up on the web
dissolution of charter schools in North
in North Carolina
and there's a process in order for them
to get
this age you're talking about they have
to have a plan and and either the bank a
guarantee that they have the substance
to support if if the dissolution occurs
and they have they have to put that up
that's the payback that
yeah and so you might want to look at
what North Carolina has on the web it's
just North Carolina Charter School
dissolution I think you should hit it
but that is certainly an issue which
that committee is looking at but if if a
school can do this
then why would they not be allowed to
receive some support building Aid as
they do with leasing that's
so they're they're they're putting up
you know are all these 501c3s
I don't I don't know the answer to that
yes I think they are
but
yeah right and so there is information
um in secretary state's office under
non-profits
um annual reports filed by all those uh
corporations also all those 501 c3s
so let's take a little break here but um
we we've raised some questions that when
we meet again we're going to try and get
some answers coming in on on the when
the the men's one you mentioned this
right now Mel
dissolution and the ability to pay off
that debt
um
so what we need to do is let them come
in and put this thing together uh let's
just take a break and come back at about
five minutes of 11 I think that that's
when they said they'd have about ready
and we'll tap in with uh ACS at that
time
thank you
all right
um
LSR
yeah there's a guy that called my wife
and and uh from I didn't add in that
last yeah I can send that to you what
I've got
um Louisiana
LSR okay the Newberry plan
so I don't know maybe if we show them
your
I think if you go ahead and turn on your
microphone yeah
hear you oh okay that's all I had to do
yes
yes okay folks here at the committee we
have here
um we have ECS and Joe Moore is here
with us from ECS he's right there on the
screen
um I'm Rick Ladd for folks at your end
I'm chairing the education committee
here and we're in the process of looking
at
um School building Aid
and our formula in New Hampshire
is one of which
it needs real good look uh we're not
able to fund the buildings that we need
to fund uh currently under that model uh
we we have with us today Amy Clark who
is from doe she is an engineer that's
very familiar with the program and with
the statutes associated with school
building aid but what we're looking at
is try and find out are there any other
states out there that might have some a
different way of funding this this uh
real need for having facilities that
reflect what we require for instruction
and curriculum in our classrooms we have
a number of buildings in our state which
are well over 50 years old and some I
hear one down in Berlin here which which
uh represents from that's 90 how many
years old
98 years old that's the building they're
in so we we have a long way to go so
so Joel if you could go ahead and and
help us out we'd appreciate it
absolutely thank you so much chill out
and thanks for the to the committee for
having us uh Chris they're able to get
the PowerPoint up for us awesome well
just very briefly want to introduce ECS
to the folks who may not be familiar we
are a national nonpartisan education
policy Center we were created through an
interstate compact back in the 1960s and
so we exist in all those State statutes
around the country and our goal is to
help all policy makers in the State uh
whether it's the legislature or the
governor's office Department offices of
fire education or Workforce Development
to create better policy that works for
them again we are non-partisan and
non-advocacy so we're not coming at this
with any particular angle or telling you
how to look at any of the information
average State obviously has its own
context and you have that best for New
Hampshire but we can't tell you what the
other 49 states are doing and what that
looks like for them so how we do that
I've got a great policy team here that
follows every Bill and every rule of
Regulation he comes out of Departments
of Education around the country we track
those compile them and regularly release
research and reports one of those uh
that we're here to talk about today my
colleague Chris duncombe has recently
completed a 50-state comparison on how
States fund School Capital Construction
so I will turn it over to Chris for that
conversation
thank you John thank you chairman live
can you hear me all right uh you're
coming in fine at this end
great perfect Powell thank you all for
having me here today us talk State
support for school facilities
no I was just asking another member to
sit down where he could see the screen
go ahead
great well thank you all for having me
here today this is a topic that we've
seen a lot of interests recently from
State leaders so happy to share some of
our recent research on this topic area
people tend to think of school
facilities as largely just a local
responsibility but states can and do
play a significant role in building a
maintaining school facilities so today
I'm going to touch on a few topic areas
first is just some initial context I'm
going to provide some background on
revenues and who pays for school
construction and how New Hampshire
compares to other states
then I'll share findings from the
research we completed that Joel
mentioned on our first 50 state in
comparison on K-12 School construction
and the types of financial assistance
that states provide as well as going
through some of the key design choices
that states have in determining that
financial assistance and then finally
chairman Ladd um in our initial
conversation the herds and interests and
allocation methods so I'm going to
provide a couple State examples that may
be helpful as you're looking to
um
perhaps change our model in New
Hampshire
so in terms of
Revenue sources nationally as you all
are probably familiar state governments
are the largest source of operating key
College support they surpass local
governments in the 1980s
States play uh smaller but still a
significant role in K-12 Capital
expenditures they contribute 22 of all
costs which is equal to an average
annual outlay of 54 billion dollars
you'll you'll notice if you see the time
periods on the slide that for Capital
expenditures that's average over an 11
period 11-year period and that's because
Capital expenses are much more important
to variation and I'll go into that in a
little bit more detail soon
um so it's average over a longer period
so it's not skewed by one particular
year of large or no investment
there's also a substantial state to
state variation so State context really
does matter for example 10 states
provide more than 50 percent of capital
costs and that includes New Hampshire
and many of you are New England
neighbors including Connecticut Maine
Massachusetts and Rhode Island
meanwhile other states provide less than
that and some states provided no Capital
Construction Aid and it was required
entirely a local responsibility
um
so it really does vary for New Hampshire
to show the data on Revenue sources
New Hampshire is somewhat unique in that
on the operating side most of the
revenue sources come from local sources
and this local Reliance is likely due
back New Hampshire does not collect or
personal income tax on wages or salaries
or state by general sales tax the state
does play a larger role in funding
Capital expenditures the state funded
over half of the capital costs from 2009
to 2019 and that compares quite
favorably to the National Data I shared
on the previous slide showing that
states on average provided just 22
percent of the costs
the data if you're interested in is from
from the operating side is on National
Center of Education statistics on the
capital side is from the 21st century
School fund state of our schools report
and I have that linked and the resources
slide at the end of this presentation if
you're interested in getting more
information on
um funding and funding sources
funding does not only vary from state to
state but it also varies over time
Capital Construction funding is very
volatile the graph I have on the slide
provides inflation adjusted data from
U.S census bureaus and your service will
system finances the performance of the
economy results in much larger swings in
capital funding from both States and
local governments compared to operating
expenses on facility maintenance that
you see in the slide following the 0709
reception Capital expenditures dropped
26 percent while maintenance and
operation support climbed to six percent
and so that's not to say that in a six
percent decline isn't is nothing
distracting a significant budgetary
impacts but it's not the more extreme
variation that occurs on the capital
spending side
similarly during more recent economic
growth Capital expenditures have
increased dramatically and part of the
reason why I think we've heard so much
from State leaders on this topic area
Rising 27 or maintenance and operations
supporting the stayed fairly stable
and I provide this information just as
for financial planning note especially
with concerns about a fiscal flip with
the exploration of federal relief
dollars and um potential for the
downturn of the economy at some point
so going into the research that we've
completed at ECS
um we provide these uh 50 state
comparisons to give leaders on a
national landscape on what we kind of
identify as some of the key decision
points this is the first year we've done
the Capital Construction 50 state
comparison so if there's any gaps that
you identify if you get a chance to take
a look at the database to the
information I share today we're
certainly open to suggestions and we're
improving and refining it
from a high level we found that 90 of
states provide some rule in supporting
School construction either through
appropriating funds directly to
districts or by writing some type of
financing support
the research also made clear that state
leaders have a lot of different
decisions to consider in providing that
support such as how to prioritize
projects whether there's a dedicated
Revenue Source in the state or a
separate Authority finances projects if
voter approval is required for standard
local debt issuance or if there's an
incentive for consolidation projects and
this diversity funding approaches does
create an opportunity for states to
potentially learn from one another and
that's what we hope this 50 state
convinced and can be helpful in doing we
have the full databases on our website
acs.org and we're happy to share any
data points of interest directly with
that committee
before going further I didn't want to
clarify some of the the differences and
the terms that I'm using when I say
Appropriations uh and financing support
Appropriations refer to funds
distributed to school districts often
through a categorical grant program
outside of their primary funding formula
and these dollars can be used for
upfront costs or paying off locally
issued debt
that distinction here as the state does
not require repayment
financing support is State assistance
that can take the form of bond issuance
guaranteeing locally issued bonds or
loaning money to districts from a state
revolving Loan Fund and the distinction
being the state requires full or partial
repayment
in terms of what we found
but we've got that 10 states provide and
I will note that this is based upon our
view of statutory language and the most
recently enacted budget so let's not say
that
um states have not done things
differently in the past but this is what
we found from current policy we found
that 10 states provide Appropriations
but do not provide financing support as
you see on the slide
seven states and DC provide financing
but do not appropriate funds directly to
districts
and 28 States including New Hampshire
provide both Appropriations and
financing support
and five states that we identified for
the most recently enacted budget did not
provide either so overall that's 90
percent of States providing some form of
financial assistance
going into some of the design choices
that we we flagged as potentially of
Interest as states are looking to design
their school construction Aid one of the
most important roles that we thought in
the state who play in this is to try to
equalize wealth disparities across
districts it's the same with operational
funding the state can play role in
equalizer and supporting Federal Capital
Construction costs and they do that by
Factory and local ability to pay States
use this factored prioritize which
projects or receiving funds the amount
that they're eligible to receive or both
New Hampshire has the
um has an index that
the
what is the name of that index sorry the
wealthy
um you're the only main factor as an
equal evaluation for people and median
income included in it so you all do have
a ability to pay a lot of States take a
few variety of approaches in this the
most common is an assessed property
value per student which is included in
your school building in Factor
almost every state with wealth
Equalization as this included as at
least an element of their local ability
to pay measure
States also factor in a few other items
such as household income New Hampshire
as median household income or childhood
poverty rates for the percentage of
students receiving free or lose price
meals levels of deadiness compared to
property values unemployment rates
and Nevada factors in declining property
values which is a unique measure
another key decision that we saw in
designing this Aid is
um to deal with the volatility that I
shared earlier some states made dedicate
funding for school construction other
than General funds as general funds may
not be dedicated to school construction
and tough Economic Times as as there may
be more pressing and immediate needs
that require the use of those funds so
one strategy is to try to provide some
stability by dedicating a revenue Source
we identified 19 states that have a
dedicated Revenue source
the most common being Lottery proceeds
or taxes on Casino gaming six states
that we identified did that states may
also use a sales and use tax as another
common source and this could be
dedicating the state share our local
share of sales tax states may also
provide a local option to raise sales
tax for school construction I don't have
them on this slide but both Virginia and
Georgia have that as an option
other common Revenue sources include
Severance taxes on natural resources for
a lot of the energy rich States or
revenue from tax assignment or marijuana
sales whether that's medical or
recreational
and the last examples being
um fees collected from either licensing
fees or on criminal fines fees and poor
pictures
another challenge facing school
districts is maintaining too many rather
than too few school facilities given
that changing demographics across the
country it's also being experienced in
New Hampshire with declining student
populations this is an increasing
challenge we identified 29 states that
provide a financial incentive for
districts to consolidate
the most common was some type of a whole
harmless Vision usually that last thing
one to five years saying that
Consolidated District can't get less per
student than they would have received if
the two districts had remained separate
states also prioritize and provide
additional
um dollars for construction projects New
Hampshire provides additional for
student dollar applications for
Cooperative school districts so not
Consolidated but districts that are
sharing services
some states may also provide an
additional weight through their formula
to boost support
another example that we saw was States
offering the lower of the two ability to
pay measures for the two consolidating
districts so the state would take on a
larger share of costs for a certain
period usually similar to Lasting as the
whole harmless policies
and Arizona is unique and they have
different local Revenue limits for
Consolidated districts
another approach that states have taken
including New Hampshire is to establish
a separate authority to provide
oversight and management of debt
specific to school construction and to
issue debt that is not at the full faith
and credit of the state
we identify at least 16 States and not
all
um authorities provide full-facing
credit outside of the state but some do
we identified at least 16 states that
have established these authorities
including New Hampshire school building
authority
other states provide financing support
do so through uh department at the state
typically in Department of Revenue or
the state treasurer
and other states just have local
financing to construct projects
some of the takeaways in doing this
research that I wanted to share for the
trend of those those High effort states
that we saw
um based on the state that are spending
the most from the 21st century School
funds database and what we found in our
research the states being Alaska
Massachusetts New Jersey Ohio Wyoming is
that they steered some common features
they typically have a grant that's
available District that takes into local
ability to pay
the state issues bonds to finance
projects at lower interest costs and
districts would be able to obtain on
their own and some have established a
separate financing Authority and then
finally a dedicated Revenue to provide
some some stability prepared to general
fund Appropriations
so I'm going to go into the last topic
here and then happy to have more of a
session
um
in terms of allocation methods a state
allocation approaches can be really
quite complex some states have multiple
grants with very different approaches
that add to that complexity so in effort
to simplify a PlayStation purchase into
really large categories allocations that
are driven by formula and allocations
that are driven by an application
process
formula allocations are specifics are
specified in state law or the state
budget in our 50-state comparison we
identified a variety of formula driven
allocations the states May factor in
local ability to pay which I had
mentioned previously and those are
typically identified by formula
States may also distribute or determine
how much funding is available for a
particular projects based on formula
that may factor in enrollment of some
number of students that are served by a
project that is being proposed they may
also factor in square footage of the
project or cost per square footage
they can be quite simple in Idaho a
single dollar amount is allocated per
student to all districts based on their
attendance counts or they can be quite
complex Maryland's capital Improvement
program allocates Aid on enrollment
projections Baseline square footage cost
per square foot local ability to pay
States also allocate funds based on
competitive application process and this
is where the state designates an agency
or a separate body to review
applications and award funds the review
process can have a degree of
subjectivity in which the reviewing body
has is given a list of priorities and is
told to allocate funds based on those
priorities or you can have a more
objective clearly defined scoring
processes and I'll offer a few State
examples that I've seen in doing the
database North Carolina is one example
they have two separate Grant programs
both funded by Lottery revenues
you know first the public school Capital
funds is a program funded annually with
100 million dollars from Lottery
revenues that's required in the state
statute that deposit and is allocated to
all the school districts in the state
and is based off solely on average daily
membership
they also have a needs-based capital
funds and districts must apply to
receive these grants the eligibility to
receive them is based on assessed
property values the adjusted market
value taxable property must be less than
40 billion dollars to be eligible
and in that application process the
north the North Carolina Department Of
Destruction reviews applications and
prioritize based on a set list of
criteria that includes debt tax ratios
whether the project is addressing
critical deficiencies and adequately
serving student populations whether it's
a consolidation project whether the
district has received one of these
commands previously and a few other
criteria
another example is New Mexico New Mexico
created a council to assist districts in
applying for Construction Grants and to
review and award funds membership on the
council is specified in statute has nine
members includes the governor the SUV
superintendent of Public Instruction and
a variety of executive and legislative
appointments
the council has a more sophisticated
approach for awarding funds than I don't
know maybe not sophisticated is the
right word but a
a more formulated approach to awarding
funds they rely on a facilities
assessment database to prioritize
applications this database is populated
with information that is gathered
through Capital master plan submitted by
districts to the state and by field
assessments to determine School
efficiencies the council uses the
applications
um
based on the information collected in
the database to create a facility index
condition and that index ranks all the
project applications and that is how
they determine how to award funds so I
would say this is a slightly more
rigorous application-based approach
rewarding funds
so I'll leave you with some of the
resources that I've mentioned and also
send this also to the subcommittee so
that you have all the access to all this
information and thank you for helping me
go through these slides and I'm happy to
have a bit more of a conversation
well thank you very much Chris that's
informative it's it's a broad picture
uh
right now from the committee are there
any questions or need for additional
information you may have heard from
Chris uh from the presentation
I I have a question just to start out
with um under the allocation method she
mentioned that Idaho
as a single dollar amount which they
allocate each year based upon must be
average daily membership fit in
residence or something such as that
how do they take into account
but how would they take into account the
needs that a high school may have need
for more space more square footage than
than a grade school
so so
we've had some discussion regarding
funding based upon population student
enrollment
um
I I guess the question is has that
allocation process run into any problems
with the needs of specific buildings for
different age levels
thank you chairman
um that's a great question and we did
see a lot of states that that factor in
grade level and their application of
project announced I can I can go through
and grab a few examples of those States
and provide them to Idaho actually has I
mentioned one of their grants they have
two grants that they provide that first
grant is they allocated just on average
daily attendance they use attendance as
opposed to enrollment account students
so it's an attendance account and it's a
flat amount so it does not vary based
upon student grade level but they also
have a separate grant that is it's kind
of similar to to North Carolina where I
mentioned they have this enrollment
driven and this needs based and then
they also have a needs-based grant that
is available to eligible districts I
don't believe that Grant either takes
into account grade level but that is a
factor that some states have done
um
seeing if I can find an example
Arizona is a state that does that
Arkansas
California
Delaware
Florida so there's there's quite a few
examples of states that are taking into
account grade level and it can provide
that complete list and additional
information on those states to members
of the committee so that's basically
you're you're talking about your average
daily membership but they're also taking
into account how many are in Middle
School how near and Elementary School
how many are in the high school
and taking up and so would they be
funded at different levels based upon
the school
grade level they may be in
like we have about 32 percent of our
kids are high school kids the remainder
of course all k through eight
yeah
um I I some states will have more
complex formulas so I don't think it's
as straightforward as a single different
dollar amount per grade level but but
um it adjusts it isn't factored into the
formula so it will eventually impact the
the overall dollar amount that is
allocated for a project
um and States may also factor in grade
level and their ranking of products
okay
are there are there other questions for
Chris right now yes represent dry
thank you that was really well presented
thank you very much
um do you take charter schools into
account this because that's the reason
we're here today does that affect any of
these
other states
I'm sorry
um representative did you ask about
charter schools and their eligibility to
receive funds yeah how does that factor
in the other 49 states
um I've seen in some of states that are
explicit in charter schools are
ineligible and some states where charter
schools are eligible
um Oklahoma's Rosebud grants are an
example
um this is a grant program they
established recently that is funded
through medical marijuana sales that's
allocated to districts and as allocated
off of their Equalization method and
charter schools are eligible to receive
those grants
that is the one that came up in the
database that we did but there may be
other state examples where Charters are
eligible
thank you
yes representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair and and
thanks so much for uh for for presenting
to us this morning
um is there a way that that we can also
um
have have an ability to compare New
Hampshire Charter Schools structure with
Charter Schools from other states
because
um
um you know my my understanding is that
is that New Hampshire has a has has very
specific
um
um uh corporate structure surrounding
Charters that that may vary from you
know maybe different from that of of of
other states and for example some
charters in New Hampshire can could be
chartered by the local school district
um we have none I think currently that
fall into that category we have no
Charter conversions
none so so the charters that we do have
are our private Corporation Charter
Charters and um uh but their New
Hampshire corporations I believe
um uh but but I think the charters in
New Hampshire are very different than
for example the charters in
Massachusetts
am I correct on that I I couldn't
compare it to Matt I don't know but yeah
but but I you know so so if we were to
if we were to say look at how and I'm
just picking for the sake of discussion
how Massachusetts funds
um building construction for for their
Charters that might be different than
than what New Hampshire does because of
the way their Charters are Incorporated
um is there a way that we'd be able to
to to be able to dig down to that level
of detail and really understand what
we're getting into
thank you representative yes that is a
great question and Turner schools their
structure how they're authorized many of
the policies varies upon state to state
we do a 50-state comparison on charter
school policies that we completed fairly
recently I can send that to you but I
can also reach out to the author of that
report to see if a particular State
jumped out to him in the completion of
that report
um as a good comparison State as a state
that you're looking for a state that
does some has Charters organized
similarly to New Hampshire
yeah I think that would be that would be
helpful but even ones that organize
differently
um uh understanding what what components
of their of their building aid program
May rely on those the differences in
those you know in those other states and
whether or not we would we would want to
consider including those components or
not you know um
but I think that would all be very
helpful
if if the chair yes I'll just um as as
context the information we have on
funding for charter schools in that
report has information on how funding is
determined who provides the funding does
the state provide startup or planning
grants and what kind of facilities
funding is available so there is a
facilities component in that as well
that would be great and I think for just
for just for background I think there is
a a study ongoing here in New Hampshire
with respect to uh to Charter
dissolution because of their their their
private Corporation status and
um and I don't know if that's the same
as in other states but but how how would
I mean you know I'm from the business
background and contracts always seem to
be about not not not you know when the
marriage is running great but when uh
when when things start to uh you know
come to the end come to disintegrate and
that's when the contract language starts
uh starts coming out but um but you know
what what happens in that type of
situation particularly with with
investment of public money in um in
these privately owned facilities
and you weren't here earlier today Dave
but uh there is one state which we had
uh Charter School disillusion
information we didn't go into it today
it's North Carolina okay great and they
have certain criteria that you have to
have written into your Charter to before
you're going to get this state loan or
money right that's how that can be dealt
with no that's that's that's that's
that's excellent information Rick and uh
and and I think that goes to what one of
the things you were talking about during
the session too about about having you
know specific information that's
expected in these agreements that these
Charters but also you know Co-op
agreements and things like that that
don't have a lot of standard to them
yeah right now Chris one other area that
we are hearing from our administrators
out in the school districts is that the
predictability
of when I can receive these dollars is
based upon of course legislation what we
appropriate here annually or biannually
uh this previous uh year we had and Amy
you're here behind the screen but are
you having that side we had 17 districts
applying for revenue from the state for
building Aid we approved we've approved
at this point to and possibly another
one coming
but the issue is that these school
districts in order to get an application
into the department have to jump a lot
of Hoops Financial Hoops in terms of
site plans architect fees all that and
of course they have to go to their local
tax dot uh taxpayers the the person the
community to raise those dollars and
then they're one of those that didn't
get money this given year or this
biennium uh uh so they're down 60 70 80
000 for the engineering fees it's
probably a whole lot more than that's
probably three hundred thousand dollars
and and so they never get reimbursed for
that uh seeing the projects are are just
going on to the list the subsequent year
and they may not be rated highly or not
so it's kind of a crap shoot
so predictability of resources to the
school districts really important
so what we were looking at just in
discussing earlier today is having a
flat amount of money appropriated based
upon a formula annually
which would be then put into a state
account and the school districts could
not access that funding until such time
that they had their application approved
by the department and it dealt with
either renovation or construction
and we also thought maybe it could be
used also to pay off previous debt
so are there any other states that have
similar type
logic towards owing to you know set up a
formula and so I just mentioned
thank you chairman yeah I was actually
as we were talking thinking that having
some guaranteed Grant amount could be
approached to providing stability in
addition to as I mentioned having a
designated Revenue Source other than
General funds
um in terms of other states with that
approach I mentioned Idaho has that flat
amount which I perhaps why you inquired
about it you know again it's not a as
sophisticated as what you're talking
about in terms of differentiating by
need or School type
um and I don't believe that money is
held in a reserve account that is just
allocated annually so that there is a
Dependable source of some Revenue that's
coming into districts
um
in terms of other states that award
funds without an application that's
required or prior to an application
being submitted
Kentucky does that as well let me see
sorry it's just a lot of
information to store from 50 states and
very complex policies to have available
on recall on a moment's notice um
so they also use average daily
attendance
um
and it's just a hundred dollar payment
based on Ada or average daily attendance
um
I can try to see if I can find another
state that has an example that's kind of
similar to what you're what you're
describing maybe that as opposed to just
giving you all the states that factor in
grade level I can look for another
example that better matches what you're
describing to me but
um I do think that type of approach is
um
a logical one for trying to provide some
stability to districts so that they can
handle some of these initial costs for
getting a project going
especially if there's no certainty that
they will receive approval from the
state to be funded we did we did see
that Tennessee had a program
where it's similar to what I stated
right here where they have a certain
amount of money which they allocate
based upon their attendance plus also in
the square footage uh per student per
uh type of building they're in middle
school high school
um
also like to know what's the life cycle
uh that they they they're expecting
we've heard from Amy right here it's
about 40 years uh is that pretty typical
throughout the country
um
and how do how do we factor in things
like uh the fees and construct
construction costs or uh debt retirement
into this formula
big determined for debt retirement
um
I believe that you are proposing was it
20-year yes
yeah that 20 and 30 were the two that
was the typical length that we saw in
reviewing States so that would fall
within that period
um 20 year being the most common okay
in terms of life cycle analysis
um I don't know if we captured all of
that through statutory language but in
looking into New Mexico's example of the
database that they use that index
um does pull in information on life
cycle analysis for the projects to
determine
um whether it be more costly to replace
or refurbish the school and so I think
that perhaps providing more information
out of that New Mexico's database
information so you might be informative
if you're interested in life cycle
information
anything we can get we're appreciating
Amy do you have any questions or
thoughts seeing that this is your your
Arena
are there any questions from from the
committee yes Dave
thanks very much Rick and and thanks
again Chris and I may have missed this
one when you were speaking
um earlier
um
but are are any states
um and that this is speaking generally
to to building Aid
um doing what New Hampshire is doing
which is uh which is a uh you know all
up front
um
type payment to the school district
or you were mentioning that a lot we're
doing 20 and 30 year more 20-year
um amortizations
yeah we identified
um sorry I thank you representative we
identified that states were either
providing their Appropriations as a
direct grant that helps cover upfront
costs and that can be done all up front
or over a series of payments
um or as a debt reimbursement and it's
pretty split
um
there were we found that it was actually
Most states were using a direct Grant
Aid or combination we found 25 States
that had Direct Grant Aid that was
helping to cover some of the upfront
costs seven states that useful direct
granted and debt reimbursement and six
states that only were doing it through
debt reimbursement process so so Most
states were kind of similar to New
Hampshire as opposed to just doing the
debt reimbursement process where
um they're just paying off annually of
locally issued debt and they have an
amortization schedule that is paying off
those okay okay no no that's good and I
want to make sure I was clear on the
question too that that um that when I
talk about a pro I'm not talking about
necessarily upfront costs or soft costs
associated with the project uh
um really talking about that the that
the you know if if um if if a project
has been approved for 10 million dollars
in in state
um building a grant that that
essentially that 10 million dollars gets
paid
um I forgot what it is in New Hampshire
eighty percent eighty percent upfront
maybe you know 10 months later but it's
essentially all up you know it's up
front as opposed to
um uh trickling out in 20 payments as
you say to help the districts help the
district cover
um uh cost of bonded debt
yeah the 80 might be a bit High I I was
answering those 25 states are are not
paying over the full length of the loan
um they are paying in a series of
installments it could be primarily up
front like you're saying New Hampshire
or you know five to
ten payments over a few years but it's
not
um it's not done
um throughout the life cycle of the
entire loan that's the deputy
reimbursement model OKAY fewer states
are doing all right so so it doesn't
have to be synchronous with the with the
term of the of the bond
um uh but but could be done
in an accelerated uh uh yeah as the
costs are being spent by the district
right okay great thanks thanks Chris
what about going further with this now
so we
what about
paying less up front you know uh to the
school district so we have more money to
incorporate more more projects more
projects
um that's another Avenue we could take
and I like what what Chris has suggested
too it doesn't necessarily have to be
synchronized with the um with the with
the the term of the bond but maybe over
maybe the if it's a 10 million dollar
project
or sorry a 10 million dollar grant that
that's paid out 2 million a year over
five years and so um so you know that
would give the district some flexibility
in terms of how they want to go
um you know the terms of paying off the
bonds well and allow us to do more more
projects too yeah I got one other
question here for you
um we do utilize uh to support those
communities which may have less of an
economic ability High property taxes etc
etc uh we we use medium family income
slash
property value our valuation of property
so
with that we have some districts get 30
percent of the of the construction costs
Others May get 60 percent
um we find even with some that are our
communities which don't really have the
economics strength the 60 is even a
tough because then that the locals have
to come up with that 40 percent and
these costs today a building suit for
talking 30 million dollars for the
building
you don't see it happening or it doesn't
the bond doesn't get approved on uh at
the local level do you have some
knowledge of states that may go above
this 60 percent that we do and maybe
going from 30 to 80 percent or 20 to 80
percent widening that out a little bit
so that we can help the the poorer towns
yeah
Connecticut is I'm sorry thank you
chairman Connecticut's 20 to 80 percent
of project costs
um there are I'm gonna see if there's
other examples of it going above 70
there's typically a range uh with a
Florida maximum
you said kinetic was 20 to 80. 20 to 80
is the range of State share
huh
that that that's
Rick that's interesting too because that
you know 2080 obviously you know a
factor of of four there in terms of in
terms of a grant um uh Grant Factor but
it's very consistent with with
um equalized valuation ranges too and
which is which is fiscal capacity yeah
that that's exactly right very
interesting it's it's something that
maybe we want to look at yeah
we've mentioned that before haven't you
Amy of going up to 80 possibly
yeah
Amy that that that
rings a bell
it does and it's not um not that we're
striving for a hundred percent but Maine
does provide close to 100 of all of
their construction projects just trying
to give you know context of whether it's
reasonable to go up to 80 percent
no that's great
hmm
are there any other you know questions
of Chris right now
Chris is this
Jen do we have the a copy of the the
PowerPoint that was just showed us or or
okay
wonderful
well you know Chris I don't think we
have any other questions here at this
time but uh we'll we'll stay in touch uh
we would like to look at some of this
information we definitely are in a a
process where we've been
allocating funds out based upon a
formula it's been around for a long long
time
and there's debt out there too of which
if we appropriate in a given year at
currently 50 million dollars half that's
going to go pay off debt that we're
obligated to pay off so it doesn't leave
a whole lot but in the same time we're
trying to put in place a formula that's
going to allow us to
sort of get away from this this process
which we have and again more
predictability and sustainability to the
formula
so
that's I guess where we are and uh it's
a challenge
the challenge is trying to transition
from where we've been to where we got to
go because the dollars are going to have
to be appropriated some sizable dollars
and we've got a pretty deep backlog
very much so
yeah
yeah we got a lot of old buildings out
there and buildings that need
replacement
so with that thank you so much for
having us yeah well Joel we really
appreciate it and of course uh we have
Gen 4 here that works with you quite
often and uh so if we have some
questions we'll work through Jen to give
you some
you know any Communications we may have
absolutely thank you so much and let's
all go through the legislative session
we're always here so uh please keep us
in mind good to see you Joel thank you
good thanks a lot have a good day yeah
have a good one
thank you
so
um
we've gone through quite a bit today
um we're at the end of this one
um
but uh I think we also have to find out
about the dissolution myth process for
the charter schools so we're going to
get a hold of Senator Lang he's not
sharing that committee
and interesting
that yeah that's all we did was organize
so but we got to go from there I think
we have two meetings set up what were
the two dates of that I I didn't write
them down
September October
October
I think
September but was September
October 4th I definitely have yeah
October 4th I thought it was September
29th also but I don't see it on the
calendar I might not happening
yeah I did neither I'll have to contact
his office
well
I guess there's a lot of information
here
um as you know the I like everybody try
to look at that uh spreadsheet that was
given out uh and see because that has
some pluses of course has some minuses
as well and as we've spoken to but uh in
in the how to apply something like that
even to the charter schools because
we're we're working off of admr they
would have to work off ADM a
and and we have a five-year average
probably be a one-year average for the
those which are owned
yes
so
in listening I've heard that maybe our
114 square feet and our price is low is
it worth reworking this with higher
numbers I I yeah you can't you can you
can take that that spreadsheet we have
it's an Excel spreadsheet so it's one
you can put plug-in you know cost per
square foot you can put square foot
that's required for grade levels in
um you can change it or from a life
cycle 40 years to 30 years by changing
the life cycle from 40 to 30 years you
have to buy another 10 million dollars
with all the other constants remaining
constant
but you could change the factors for you
know how much we're going to put in
there for equipment or architectural
fees or our debt retirement that can all
change
um I guess my point is those are
variables yeah these are two things that
I've heard today we we may just have
started at a little too low a point to
look at a good comparison
yeah yeah I did the reason why I
selected those figures is I took and and
did a uh
what was being done in that one state of
Tennessee
then I took a a a a
calculate calculator
with inflation costs or what a dollar
was back then what it would be worth now
it doesn't do what Amy would look at
actual construction costs a while if
they were initially but
um that that can all change but we got
to also calculate in here you're going
to have to pay for you're gonna have to
have that flat amount coming into the
districts annually you're gonna have to
pay off our debt as well
and then you're going to have to have
money that's available that's going to
be taking care of these projects that
come up that are emergencies that you're
not aware of
and we could be talking about initially
there we appropriate supposedly 50
million dollars a year it's going to
jump
almost twice that or or you know a
significant hunk to pay off our debt and
also get that money flowing in to uh put
the money in the the the flat amount
which they would receive and that would
change too annually based upon
demographics based upon costs of
construction
um
and like Amy said we might want to use
not just some of this money not just for
me uh construction
and
a renovation but also paying off debt
that the district currently owns
which is not a bad idea as well so a lot
to it
it's going to take us time to do it but
we need to be looking at this stuff
but I just add two chairman that I would
encourage you to use
um accurate representative numbers and
then if you need to make the dollar come
out to something that's reasonable then
you work with the percentages so that
the community can effectively
communicate that the state is not indeed
paying 60 percent they're indeed paying
32 percent or something because it
allows for better Communications because
if those numbers are not reasonable then
it really sets the school district up
for not really being able to communicate
with their Community very well
okay I can share with everybody where I
got some of those figures initially they
came from this sheet which I got from
Tennessee
um
but be aware that we do have another
bill coming at us from the Senate which
is going to be looking at this similar
type model but based solely on ADM
okay I guess we're right at noon time
so anything else
okay we're adjourned
thank you very much
I knew you'd asked see it's not in the
calendar because they had to reschedule
it from what was last Friday Thursday it
would have been last Thursday's meeting
what's the one we had this afternoon
okay yeah that's right it's adma it's
the the one where